kill every Targaryen
my hands are everyone who isn't
so I did it bring me its panties we take
what is ours
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a prediction video like I said in one of
my previous videos one of my close
friends finally decided to start
watching Game of Thrones and I had been
trying to watch as many episodes with
him as I can because I wanted to help
guide him through the series well this
past week I was able to watch a handful
of episodes and I couldn't help but get
the feeling that the show is still
hinting at a possible relationship
between Sansa Stark and Tyrion Lannister
now I know this is by no means a new
theory but if you take a look at some of
the scenes I want to show you it may
shed a little bit more light on the idea
of these two getting back together I
actually made a video about this over a
year ago in that video was titled will
songs of stark become a Lannister in
that video I talked about Sansa and
Tyrion ending up together in the end but
now I want to provide some more clues
that may prove they are foreshadowing
this actually happening now I know some
of you may be thinking aren't they
married already Tyrion and Songz's
marriage was never officially dissolved
but you have to keep in mind Tyrion and
saunas marriage was never consummated
either so it may not be viewed as a
legitimate marriage in Sansa here she's
alive and well she is that she missed me
terribly
a sham marriage and unconsummated I
didn't ask well it was it wasn't anyway
we are now heading into the final season
of Game of Thrones and they will have to
wrap everything up in six episodes which
can't be an easy task there are going to
be a lot of reunions next season and
what I'm really looking forward to
seeing is the reunion between Sansa and
Tyrion the last time they saw each other
they were married and neither of them
wanted to be forced into that situation
but now that so much has happened since
then I think them getting back together
is definitely possible but not a
guarantee now I know there are a lot of
other eligible bachelors
some people think songs that could end
up with gun jury and some other people
think so-and-so could end up with
Podrick but you have to look at it like
this if Shaun's it does happen to Mary
again what would make the most sense
Sansa has never met ginjury and she
doesn't know Podrick at all Sansa is now
in a position of power so I don't see
her being forced into a marriage ever
again which means she will only marry
someone she is willing to accept as a
partner if Santa ended up marrying
ginjury or someone else besides Tyrion I
think it would be too rushed like I said
there are only six episodes left and a
few of those episodes are going to
feature some pretty big battles which
only leaves a handful of episodes to
push this story forward
Sansa and Tyrion already have a built-in
relationship and history together they
could explain them two getting back
together a lot easier than having songs
of meat and marry someone new which what
also most likely be someone she has
never had a one-on-one scene with before
I just don't see them finding her a
brand new match with very few episodes
left they don't have enough time when
they already have so much to wrap up
what the night King and Cersei now in
order for sons in Tyrion to make their
marriage official that would mean songs
I would have to want to do this and she
hasn't shown many signs of affection for
Tyrion however she does know Tyrion is
nothing like the other Lannister's
bastards in their father's eyes
what does that mean it's something he
said to me the first night we met you
know him better than any of us what do
you think Kieran's not like the other
Lannisters who's always kind to me but
it's true greater risk Tyrion is one of
the very few people Sansa has met that
has never truly wanted anything from her
sons also knows that Tyrion would never
hurt her even on their wedding night
Tyrion promised her this Annie proved
that he would not take advantage of her
or force her to have sex with him like
Ramsay data Tyrion may not be the most
handsome man in Westeros but he does
have many other redeeming qualities
about him and this is something Sansa
may grow to admire or respect about
Tyrion Margaery Tyrell once said
something the sonzai that I thought was
very interesting and what she said may
have stuck with Sansa after all of these
years some like short men some like
hairy men some like bald men gentle men
rough men ugly men pretty men pretty
girls most women don't know what they
like until they've tried it and sadly so
many of us get to try so little before
we're old and gray Tyrion may surprise
you what I've heard he's quite
experienced at the time Sansa was still
dreaming of living out her life like a
fairy tale she wanted to marry the
handsome prince and have his babies then
one day become queen but after her time
spent in King's Landing all of those
dreams were shattered and I would bet
that her outlook has probably changed
Tyrion may not look like the person
sanso had envisioned herself settling
down with but Marjorie made a very good
point most woman do not know what they
want until they have tried it and that
doesn't just go for a woman but that
also goes for a men as well sometimes
you think you know what you want but
once you've tried it you might not want
that anymore and the thing you did not
expect alike may come along and sweep
you off of your feet sons and Tyrion
have both had very bad experiences and
relationships and I don't even think I
need to go into why we all know how
Joffrey treated Sansa and we all know
it's Shae
that up doing to Tyrion the funny thing
is Tyrion once said something to Sansa
that may have been right all along
the demon
I am the disgraced daughter the traitor
Ned Stark the disgraced daughter and the
demon monkey were perfect for each other
when referring to the both of them
Tyrion said to Sansa the disgraced
daughter and the demon monkey were
perfect for each other
there was something else Tyrion once
said that could be foreshadowing their
future like I said earlier the last time
Tyrion and Sons I saw each other was
during Joffrey's wedding after Joffrey
had ingested the poison Sansa was rushed
out of the city and Tyrion was held
responsible for Joffrey's murder during
his court hearing
Tyrion demanded a trial by combat when
Tyrion sent for Bronn he was hoping he
could convince him to fight for his
freedom once again but as we all know
bran declined his offer but during this
conversation Tyrion said something else
that I want to point out so let's take a
lesson you might be surprised
Lannister always pays his debts your
sister's a Lannister too
my wife is heir to Winterfell if I
emerge from this with my head still on
my shoulders I may one day rule the
north in her name I could carve you out
a big piece of it if and May and could
at the time Shawn's in Tyrion were still
technically married even though it was
never consummated
but Tyrion said if he was still alive
after the trial by combat he could one
day rule the north
because Sansa was his wife and she was
thought to be the only surviving heir to
Winterfell
obviously Sons is not the only stark
that is alive but Winterfell was pretty
much hers at this point bran wants
nothing to do with ruling the north and
Sansa is older than Arya now Jon was
king of the north but he gave that up
when he bent the knee to Daenerys once
John finds out he is a legitimate
Targaryen he would actually be the heir
to the entire Seven Kingdoms
but no matter how that plays out I think
Sansa will remain as the Lady of
Winterfell and this may have even been
for
shadowed back in season five during a
conversation with Littlefinger let's
take a look at this other scene I want
to show you real quick if you're right
Stannis takes Winterfell he rescues you
from the most despised family in the
north grateful for your late father's
courageous support of his claim he names
you wardeness of the north I I wouldn't
the North will be yours do you believe
me so as you can see a little finger
told sonzai that one day the North would
be hers and he was right I find this
interesting because what Tyrion said to
bran might actually come true as well
Tyrion did survive the trial by combat
just like he'd hoped and now he could
even rule the north and beyond with
Sansa at his side there is actually a
little bit of foreshadowing in the books
as well when I was rereading the books I
made sure to leave post-its on every
page that I thought might have some
foreshadowing or connections to other
things in the story and there were a few
quotes that might be hinting at a Sansa
and Tyrion relationship in the end the
potential for shadowing or even
parallels I should say happened very
early on in the books what makes these
interesting is the fact that they happen
when both characters are basically
introduced which means george RR martin
may have been hinting at this pairing
from the very beginning of the story
Tyrians official introduction is when he
talks to join snow for the first time
after their brief conversation Tyrion
leaves to head back inside and this is
what Jon thinks when he opened the door
the light from within drew his shadow
clear across the yard and just for a
moment Tyrion Lannister stood tall as it
came
then in Songz's first POV chapter this
is what it says she was a stark of
Winterfell a noble lady and someday she
would be queen both of these quotes are
written in at the very beginning of the
first book and they hint at songs are
becoming Queen and Tyrion becoming King
now this next one does actually relate
to their relationship and possible
future relationship right after Joffrey
is poisoned at his wedding Sir Dontos
helps Sansa escape from the city he
escorts heard a little fingers bow just
like he does in the television show once
songs is on his boat they talk about
what is happening and this is what was
said
Sansa tells Littlefinger they think
Tyrion poison Joffrey sir Dontos said
they seized him Littlefinger smiled
widowhood will become you Sansa the
thought made her tummy flutter she might
never need to share a bed with Tyrion
again that was what she wanted wasn't it
Littlefinger is basically telling sana
that Tyrion will die
which is why Saens
will become a widow and that made her
stomach flutter then she thinks about
not having to share a bed with Tyrion
ever again because that's what she
thought she wanted but then she
questions herself because she says
that's what she wanted
dot-dot-dot wasn't it I don't think she
wants Tyrion to die but she doesn't
truly know what she wants all she knows
is she wanted away from Joffrey and
Cersei Tyrion wasn't actually the person
who was causing her any problems and now
that she is off to god-knows-where with
Littlefinger she has no idea who she
might have to share a bed with next so
sharing wool material might not have
been that bad after all all right now
this next one actually refers to saans
and Tyrion getting married again
this is one Littlefinger takes Songza to
her aunt Liza's in the Eyrie
while Sansa is here she is worried that
she will be forced to marry her little
cousin sweet Robin and this is what
songs oh thanks to herself I will tell
my aunt that I don't want to marry
Robert not even the High Septon himself
could declare a woman married if she
refused to say the vows she wasn't a
beggar no matter what her aunt said she
was 13 a woman flowered and wed the heir
to Winterfell
Sansa felt sorry for her little cousin
sometimes but she could not imagine ever
wanting to be his wife I would sooner be
married to Tyrion again if lady Liza
knew that surely she'd send her away
away from Robert spouts and shakes and
runny eyes away from marillion 'he's
lingering looks away from that sick pedo
peters kisses I will tell her I will the
reason why I think this is interesting
is because I know some people have said
silence am i marry our cousin Robin to
secure the Vale Army for good but as you
can see right here Sansa would rather
marry Tyrion again before she would ever
marry that little [ __ ] Robin if you look
at all these things on their own they
don't really mean that much but when you
look at it as a whole I think it's
definitely a possibility that they could
get together again not a guarantee but a
possibility there is one other thing I
want to mention that I will let you go
and this could be seen as a spoiler so
please proceed with caution
some photos recently came out and it
showed nearly the entire cast in Spain
which is where they filmed their scenes
in the dragon pit this was right at the
same time that the King's Landing set in
Belle
fast was also very active well when
these photos started to come out there
was one photo that really piqued my
curiosity in this photo you can see
Sansa in Tyrians body doubles this photo
was also taken near the dragon pit at
the same time sophie turner and peter
dinkledge were in town this leads me to
believe songs in tyrion will be filming
some scenes together and they will most
likely take place in the dragon pit
since they were scheduled to film there
at this time I recently made a video
where I talked about what I thought
could be happening in the dragon pit in
that video I said John or Danny could
possibly be giving some type of speech
after they take King's Landing but there
was one other possibility I thought of
that I did not mention in that video
because I was saving it for when I made
this one about Tyrion and Sansa I will
admit this is kind of a crazy idea but
when I saw Sansa antarians body double
there as well I figured something must
happen between the two of them if
Shawn's and Tyrion do get back together
they could end up rolling together in
some capacity depending on what John and
Daenerys decide to do if this would
happen perhaps Sansa and Tyrion make
some kind of an announcement together in
the dragon pit maybe they are given the
north
just like Tyrion predicted in his
conversation with Bronn or maybe they
announced they are renewing their vows
Tyrion and Sansa will obviously be
present at the dragon pit and hopefully
they aren't just standing around let me
know what you think about all of this do
you think any of it could be seen as
foreshadowing put your comments down
below also if you haven't seen my last
two videos I just want to let you know
that I am doing a new giveaway and you
still have plenty of time to enter if
you would like to I am giving away two
prizes which means there will be two
winners I have the blu-ray boxset and
the a Song of Ice and Fire book
collection to giveaway if you want to
enter just click on the link that is
down below in the description good luck
everyone and thank you for watching the
video I also want to give a big thanks
to everyone that supports the channel on
patreon I really appreciate that I hope
you all have a great day I will see you
again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you